[Musik]
von maximilian steiner stanley fischer
für qualifizierte gebirgsbildung die
boxkampf zentrum in saalfelden und dort
den verantwortlich einerseits
jahreswechsel ausbildung und
andererseits für die handelsblockade
ausbildung
zu den aufgaben des heeres sogar etwas
zählen das bergen von verletzten oder
verwundeten soldaten aus schwierigen
gelände lufttransport bergen von
mehreren personen im rahmen einer
hochwasserkatastrophe also diese massen
irgendwie es zeichnen
zusammenfassend ein spezialist in der
zusammenarbeit mit jahresprogramm
ausbildung ist daher als bergführer
ausbildung und somit können wir
sicherstellen dass wenn das flugretter
im gebirgigen gelände eingesetzt ist
aber die notwendige körperliche
leistungsfähigkeit verfügt sich zu
bewegen weil da herrscht meistens
absturzgefahr und deswegen rechts nicht
nur dass man jetzt die flugretter
ausbildung im hause bergsteigerische und
alpinistisch in der lage sein seinen
aufträge zu erfüllen darunter
komplexität dieser verschiedenen
aufgaben die die ihm auf einen herrn
flüge dazu kommen können es besonders
wichtig dass zwischen pilot vor
techniker und neben den flugretter
besonderes vertrauensverhältnis besteht
und das kann nur dadurch erreicht werden
indem man hat regelmäßig trainiert und
vollem einsatz nahe trainiert und
deswegen wollen wir heute wieder draußen
gelände im schwierigen gelände und haben
somit im gebirge wieder einiges an
erfahrung gewinnen können
[Musik]
von harrisburg schon flug das kann
natürlich sehr sehr vielfältig weil man
sich in einem umfeld bewegt über sehr
viel passieren kommen sprechen in erster
linie natürlich im gebirge
gibt es doch hundertprozentige
sicherheit kann natürlich immer etwas
schief gehen
und deswegen ist es umso mehr bedeuten
dass ständig am ball bleibt und immer
trainiert und sich fortbilden und das
ist das ziel des lehrganges das mal dass
mir jetzt verfolgen dass man eben mal
gesagt am ball bleibt und uns ständig
sie haben dass wir nicht weiter so
der ausflug hat den kommenden drei
hubschrauber typen zum einsatz das ist
in erster linie die a3 dann die
arbeitsstation 470 und bei ihrer
hubschrauber natürlich seine stärken und
schwächen hat gibt es verschiedene
einsatzmöglichkeiten für die pflege
verwendet man in erster linie einen
kleinen wendigen und sehr
leistungsstarken steuer die alle drei
für die massen regierung sprich wenn man
jetzt im rahmen des hochwassers viele
personen evakuieren muss dann ist
natürlich die s70 black und am besten
geeignet
mit 12,14 die maßen wackeln aber auch
natürlich in die berge
[Musik]